[Music]
immigration in America is not just about
people crossing the southern border this
morning we want to focus on the places
the migrants go after they enter this
country some of those cities as you know
are really struggling to manage all the
arrivals New York City is now using old
schools and hotels to shelter busloads
of migrants sent from places like Texas
Chicago is just opened a new temporary
shelter for migrants over the weekend
and it is already filling up very
quickly Adriana Diaz visited a Chicago
Police Station where the migrants are
staying because there are no other
options
with nowhere else to go migrants are
sleeping in police stations
reversed eight countries with her young
family from Venezuela they crossed the
U.S Mexico border months ago but the
trauma feels like yesterday
the Rio Grande River and the water was
up to here and you were holding the
babies
come on
the city wants a temporary shelter in
this former school on the south side
how'd you do that without consulting us
but some residents have sued
saying in part their Community is
already strapped
incoming mayor Brandon Johnson addressed
the crisis at his swearing-in ceremony
Monday the soul of Chicago
tells us we will never close our doors
to those who come here in search of a
better life to help alleviate crowding
at police stations
the mostly Latino community of Pilsen is
building their own shelter as they fill
it installing showers even cutting hair
Doug Nguyen owns the building and worked
with local leaders and volunteers to
create this space yes there was a reason
we didn't rent it for the last couple
years I mean there must be some other
purpose right this is so much better
while there we met one-year-old Andres
and his mom Wendy Benitez
[Music]
you got here on a bus that was organized
by the government in Texas
[Music]
you heard that there were shelters with
space here in Chicago so you came to
Chicago but that wasn't the case Wendy
rondon's family spent three nights on a
police station floor her 12-year-old
Brian describes their Journey as both
good and bad
[Music]
the bad part is that they had to be on
the street sleeping on the street
Crossing Through the Jungle
[Music]
mom says the good part is that we
arrived
the number of migrants at this police
station grew between Thursday when we
were here and yesterday when we came
back and there are people inside this
building right now one of the first
orders of business for the mayor was
establishing a deputy mayor for
immigrant and Refugee Rights the local
Alderman here told us there are roughly
600 migrants at police stations across
the city Nate
it's a large number Adriana thank you